you know when we want both moral Clarity  and scientific empiricism we go to  Republicans like Marjorie Taylor green  who recently tweeted  so many people still wearing masks I  just want to ask you if a pair of  underwear or really thick Ones high  quality cotton can't protect you from a  fart then how will a mask protect you  from covid now this is Bonkers cuckoo  for Cocoa Puff stuff but  we actually talked about the science  the particles that carry the waft of her  farts  are smaller  than the particles that carry covet  and so the fart smell can get through  where covet doesn't  that's the science I don't know if  Marjorie necessarily cares about that